we don't get to the place that we're all
not trying to cancel each other we will
all cancel each other if you figure out
a trick that will silence your opponents
and it consistently works you're gonna
keep going back to it and that almost
explains why we're in the hysterical
place that we're at right now where you
can wear this this thing this sort of
hysteria around the left where they're
just attacking everybody and if Nancy
Pelosi says saying about AOC then AOC
says Nancy Pelosi is a racist because
it's a snake that eats its own tail but
there's a there's a reason for that
which is if you own the media if you
only establishment if you own the
parameters and the Overton Window that
the conversation is allowed to have
allowed to exist in well then when when
people start making some good points and
eventually those cries stop working
you've gotten fat on not working out not
working out your ideas so if you say I
mean this is I see this all the time it
when I started sort of evolving on some
of the stuff I always tell people I
really believe the same things that I've
always believed I would say the one
place that I've really shifted is
economics where I certainly have shifted
more right and if you say to somebody
you know I'm for low taxes if you say to
a lefty I'm for low taxes you will often
find I'm sure you guys have had this
happen to you at college they will say
you're racist and you say well well what
what does that mean and they say well if
you're for low taxes that means you
don't want to help poor people and if
you don't want to help poor people that
somehow means you don't want to help
black people and if you don't want to
help black people you're racist and they
take you on this crazy adventure through
that now you can you can give them all
the the numbers right where the more we
pour money into these places and into
these districts you could look at all
the places where black unemployment the
highest and it's always Democrat run
cities and all of those things they're
not gonna really respond to that but
eventually I really believe this and I
think this is why probably people care
about my show eventually if you do your
best to just be a little bit better than
them and calmly try to explain to them
but just because you feel something is
right it feels right to say Oh
somebody's poor I want to give them
something and then they never want to
give it themselves right they want to
sue they want somebody else to give it
but it feels Oh somebody's poor
I'm gonna give them something or any of
these things it all feels right and
that's why Shapiro's line been Shapiro's
line but facts don't care about your
feelings that's why that really took off
because if you can sit there with them
long enough to get them over their
feelings and it ain't gonna be easy and
I guarantee you everyone in this room
has lost friends probably over politics
and probably not by your choice it's
pretty rare that I find a conservative
or a libertarian or a classical liberal
that just can't take somebody on the
left anymore it usually is the other way
because they will say all those awful
things about you
but if you're a little bit better than
them and it's gonna take practice and
patience then I think you can break
through to them and I think that's what
I've tried to do with my show to varying
degrees of success I suppose yeah a
million YouTube subscribers is uh we're
trying to reach that yeah we'll get
there someday so I want to talk a little
bit more about kind of the the mob
mentality because I think that you've
been kind of at the forefront of trying
to I shouldn't say trying but having to
cope with this you know being somebody
that has transitioned you know from kind
of I mean the Young Turks to be more
classical liberal it's got to be
interesting for you to witness I would
say this you know canceled culture on
our roads you know we got a lot of fire
this week as we put out a piece in The
Washington Times about this whole Dave
Chappelle special and just you know how
we shouldn't it's it's a shame to see
the gut reaction from so many people
that are just commenting or even some
journalists that put out you know that
YouTube should pull this down there
Netflix should pull this down and do you
think it gets worse before it gets
better
like do we hit it do we hit a point
where it's like you know something I
mean Chappelle talked about this where
something you tweeted when you were you
know 20 years old a lot of people in
this room are gonna be in that that age
bracket are we gonna hit a spot where
people are numb to it and it's like
listen we all did that stuff or we and
and what we better get on that place we
better when do we get there the thing is
we have to get there if we don't get to
the place that we're all not trying to
cancel each other we will all cancel
each other we will end up in a in a
totalitarian state not necessarily
because of the government which I know
for most people in this room that's the
big fear it will be because we have
silenced ourselves I mean the amount of
people that I meet that are just good
decent people right like just decent
people that tell me all the time I'm
afraid to say what I think I'm afraid to
post that no people will tell me they're
afraid to post my videos and I'll go
think about this this is we're not in
Pakistan where if you're a blogger you
could be shot on the street we're not
there yet but we actually could start
veering there if every time a good
person like you guys if every time you
won't say what you think especially when
you're 18 19 years old you guys will
never have more passion and and
wherewithal and and lack of world
weariness to say what you think then
right now like it doesn't get easier you
know there's I think there's this belief
that for a lot of college students but
somehow like oh if I can just suck it up
now you know don't say what I think now
get the grade so I can get into grad
school get into grad school so I can get
the job if I can just be quiet now I'll
later on I'll start saying what I think
and it's like that is the reverse of
reality I don't know if you guys know
this but one day you're gonna have to
have a job and then you're gonna have a
house and a car and a dog and a wife or
a husband and kids and so you're gonna
have all this and you're gonna go
now I'm gonna start telling the world
what I think know it every day that you
don't do it is just is just chipping off
your ability to ultimately do it so you
gotta fight it and trust me they haven't
killed any of us yet I mean for those of
you that you know yet here in America I
mean really think of it I was sad that
you had to laugh at that but but but
think about that I mean for the for the
people that have been on my show that
you know that have survived the mob
Jordan Peterson survived the mob why did
the mob come after him because all he
said was I'm not against trans people
but I don't want the government to be
able to dictate my speech relative to
what pronouns I use when referring to
them he said I'll treat trans people
respectfully if they treat me
respectfully but the government can't
come and say that the mob went after him
tried to destroy him Bret Weinstein
didn't want the school where he worked
Evergreen State to be segregated one day
a year based on the color of skin I'm
pretty sure Martin Luther King would
have been down with that the mob tried
to destroy him Brett didn't get
destroyed these guys are bigger now
and use their examples Lindsey Shepherd
from wilfred laurier who all she did was
show a video of jordan Peterson in a
class as a TA and they tried to destroy
her they will keep doing it but if you
show a little bravery you you can spread
that bravery to you an untold amount of
people and we have a bravery deficit in
the country right now and we have a
group of people that are more than happy
to take advantage of that let me talk to
you about one of the things that you did
that I think was one of the most
courageous or fiscally irresponsible
decisions I've seen oh good god I've
made several of these so I don't know
where you're going so you know you
taking yourself off some of these
platforms you know whether it's patreon
YouTube I mean I want to talk a little
bit about just kind of big tech and
where you think the now I'm gonna say
where is it going but give me I mean
kind of your analysis for students what
what do you think has happened that has
forced these tech companies to get to a
point where I mean we're clearly seeing
some bias we're clearly seeing some
censorship and I want to ask this
question again I mean does it get better
or do we just see the marketplace work
where people actually leave some of
these mega tech corporations and I'm
also going to throw this in there a lot
of individuals and I will give you
credit for this have jumped to say the
government should be stepping in and
dictating how these companies can
operate now I don't take that stance I
haven't seen you take that stance I
appreciate that but I worry because I
mean you see people like Josh Hawley and
some of these other conservatives who
that's what they're trying to do they're
trying almost fight fire with fire and
get the government involved so think
about what an interesting situation we
have right now I I was right before I
went off the grid for the month for
August which I think we're gonna talk
about oh yeah I threw public pressure he
was the only way I could get a response
out of YouTube I had to keep shaming
them on Twitter because they're one of
their Whistler whistleblowers that came
out that was an employee of Google
specifically said my name as one of the
people that they're censoring so I kept
going on Twitter and I kept tagging
Susan Wojcicki who's the YouTube CEO and
finally she followed me and we had a
we had a video call a Skype call it was
off the record then I I was going up to
Silicon Valley so we had a meeting again
off the record and I won't repeat
anything that was said off the record
but I will say one thing that I I told
her at the end I said you know I'm
basically the last guy that's not
calling for government intervention
right now I mean think about this
Elizabeth Warren wants to break up big
tech and Tucker Carlson wants to break
up big tech they agree on basically
nothing now I obviously generally
speaking I agree far more with Tucker
Carlson than I do with Elizabeth Warren
and Tucker as a friend and a nice guy
but this is a really interesting spot if
you're if you're a liberty-loving person
if you're a limited government person
and yet you understand that we are in a
truly unique position right now this is
what is happening with big tech the
amount of information that Google
controls the amount they know about
every single thing that you do that
every single one of us has an iPhone or
something like it in our pocket the way
they can use the algorithms to make you
think a certain way the way that if you
start thinking one way they can actually
shift the way you think by suggesting
certain videos and not suggesting other
things the way they can shadow ban you
on Twitter and the way that you can
subscribe to videos and then not get
from a certain creator because that
doesn't fall in line what they like this
is a problem that is almost unthinkably
huge but is this the moment that we then
want to then give the power to the
government you're on Brooke from a are i
from iran institute who i'm sure many of
you guys know i did a panel with him
discussing this and he said the sort of
purist attitude on this which is well if
you don't have principles when they
matter then what's the point of having
them and i am trying my hardest as
someone that makes a living doing this
that is trying to communicate the ideas
that i believe in i am trying my hardest
not to be one of those people that at
the end is just gonna be like you know
what it regulate the hell out of
them i don't want that if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell